hey you guys time once again for
flickers of fear and this is going to be
our last installment in our folk horror
february series now this is a movie that
i knew pretty much nothing about
um i just i think i brought it up on
some of my previous folklore reviews but
shudder not too long ago uh since they
had added this very expansive
documentary about uh the folk horror
subgenre had also added a whole bunch of
folk horror movies from pretty much
every era
and i believe there's 47 of them in
there 40 somewhere around there 45 46
and so a lot of those i had not seen so
some of these i wanted to kind of get
into now i watched a couple of them and
i didn't love them um so i was just kind
of like well i kind of need one to do
for the last show
so i picked this one just sort of at
random because it was from the 80s
uh 1989 to be specific and it was
australian and uh you know i usually
have pretty good luck with uh australian
films so this is a movie called celia it
was also marketed under the name celia
child of terror but i will say
even though this does have
some
very very slight folk horror uh elements
to it does have some kind of a little
bit of magical realism fantastical
elements to it
not really a horror film and i do kind
of feel like uh that
you know the the fact that it was
marketed as that
maybe would um
caused people to sort of be like
disappointed when they watched it which
i think is a shame because this is
actually a really good film and now as i
said
it does have horror elements to it this
kind of but
to be honest i'm not really sure what
genre i'd call is it's kind of like a
period piece
coming of age drama but it has
fantastical elements in it honestly it
kind of gave me a similar kind of vibe
to
i don't know maybe the lady in white
although that was a little bit more
fantastical or maybe something like
paper house uh the british film
something like that where it's kind of
like it's also kind of like low-key
maybe a precursor to maybe some
guillermo del toro's stuff again not as
fantastical
but
in the sense that it's showing
real-life horrors you know real-life
things going on during a particular time
period sort of filtered through a
child's
perception of a very imaginative child
who sees uh particular things in a
particular way so
um i mean i really liked this movie but
i've seen
um you know it did seem to get like
fairly decent uh reviews even at the
time
but i've seen some modern day reviews
uh of people who didn't realize that it
wasn't a horror film straight up and
were kind of like what the [ __ ] am i
watching this is not a horror movie
which like i said it's not but it does
have horror elements to it there is kind
of like a little bit of like some dream
sequences with like monsters and things
like that and as i said there are some
real life horror in this as well
i will say too i found this and maybe i
think i talked about this a little bit
on my review of lamb as well
any movie that has uh an animal
as kind of like a major character which
this has as well
uh and you always kind of know
just because of the tone of the film you
always kind of know that maybe something
bad is gonna happen to the animal those
kind of movies i've i find them very
very difficult to watch as i said i'm a
real big horror fan i can watch terrible
things happening to humans all day long
and it doesn't really bother me but the
second you do something to an animal a
particularly a cute one
i'm gonna get upset so i will say
that um just from the outset
if you really really like rabbits if
you've ever had pet rabbits um you know
or or anything of that nature
uh this is gonna upset you because
honestly uh it upset me as well and uh
you know it's it just it really really
bothered me like toward the end
because
something bad does happen a couple of
bad things uh happened to a rabbit
matter of fact uh but you know i'll get
into that in a little bit but i'm just
saying that if you are very like
soft-hearted toward animals as i am uh
this i found those bits like very very
difficult to watch and again just like
when i was watching lamb
because that was also had an animal or
at least like an animal human hybrid as
a main character and uh so it really
kind of like gives me this feeling of
dread in the pit of my stomach the whole
time because i just know something bad's
gonna happen that animal and i don't
really want to see it you know what i
mean but so this movie had that as well
so i was like really stressed out the
whole time i actually did not mind that
this wasn't a horror movie because i
went into it
because i was looking through all of the
shutter ones uh that i hadn't seen and i
was like oh that looks pretty good it's
gonna you know it's about a little girl
set in australia and it's from the 80s
and i had never heard of it
um so i didn't really just read like the
sentence and then i scrolled down a
little bit and there were um you know a
couple of reviews and pretty much every
reset well it's not a horror film really
but i'm still glad i watched it it was
still really good and that's kind of how
i feel about it too so i went into it
not really knowing not really thinking
that it was going to be a horror movie
and i think that that's how you should
probably approach it as i said it does
have
some horror elements to it
but it's
more a period piece or a coming of age
drama with just kind of like some
fantastic or horror elements uh as well
so this was actually as i mentioned came
out in 1989 uh it was written and
directed by anne turner
uh rebecca smart
plays uh the titular character celia who
is a nine-year-old girl
i will say too all the child acting in
this there are a lot of kids in it uh
was amazing and i'm not a person that's
a big fan of child actors and movies
generally
but they were actually all very good in
this they were all very natural
and especially since this was made in
the 80s but it's actually set in the
1950s uh i really did
get a sense that these were actual
children from the 1950s like the way
they were acting was just very very
naturalistic none of them were annoying
or anything like that
so what we have celia the main character
she's kind of growing up it's set in
1957 uh on the outs because she kind of
lives in a small town
on the outskirts of melbourne australia
now a lot of stuff you know two of the
big things that are going on in the
background of this that kind of like
factor into the plot a lot like as it
goes on
are uh the whole red scare cold war type
things in 1957
you know sputnik and all of that
and uh so there's a lot of stuff about
uh you know people being quote unquote
dirty reds all these kind of like uh
fears in australia of like communist
parties like infiltrating blah blah blah
so that's kind of going on a lot in the
background it does factor into the plot
later on
and also as i mentioned before about the
rabbits
um anybody knows much of anything about
australian history knows that they had
particularly 1950s there was kind of
like
rabbits being considered an invasive
species because you know rabbits they
reproduce like rabbits i mean that's a
phrase for a reason and they were kind
of taking over and like a really really
affecting uh the agriculture in the
country because the rabbits were pretty
much eating everything
so there was this big thing where uh
governments where they were trying to
purge like all the rabbits from the
country so
in this movie
there are like some actual uh you know
there are some type there are some times
where the characters are watching
news footage or like you know they'll be
in a movie theater and there's like a
newsreel like before the movie and it's
kind of about
you know this is how many millions of
rabbits got killed so there is actual
news reel footage of
you know this this huge purge of rabbits
that happened back in the 1950s
so that's kind of going on in the
background as well again these are two
big things that were going on in real
life in the 50s in australia at the time
that factor into this uh one little
girl's story
so this little girl as i said she's very
imaginative and apparently you don't
you don't really see it like you know
but prior to the events of the movie
you're led to believe that she's
actually very very close was actually
very close to her grandmother now at the
very beginning of the movie her
grandmother dies like she just dies in
her sleep and celia finds her dead in
the bed and she is obviously like really
inconsolable
now for a time
she still sees her grandmother uh around
sometime like she hallucinates her and
like talks to her and stuff
and again this is not this is a little
bit unspoken but you're kind of led to
believe that because her parents
her mom is okay but i mean her mom seems
like a nice enough lady but her mom is a
little bit of um
she just kind of goes along with
whatever her husband uh you know celia's
dad wants and celia's dad is a [ __ ]
nightmare he is a [ __ ] jerk wad of
massive massive proportions and like the
whole
the whole movie i was sitting there
going please let something bad happen to
that guy which i know is probably not
what you're supposed to think i mean he
is i don't know if i'd go so far as to
say he is supposed to be a villain but
the movie doesn't portray him as a good
person i mean he's a [ __ ] you know and
so we'll get into that a little bit
but so we're led to believe that there
was prob that celia was actually much
closer to her grandmother mainly because
her parents didn't really get her or
didn't really understand her as i said
her mom is fine her mom's a nice lady
but her mom's a little bit mousy you
know what i mean so like the dad is kind
of like very much this my way of the
highway type uh dude and she just kind
of goes along with it even if she thinks
it's [ __ ] up um so she actually the
mom actually does have a little bit of a
character arc later on when she actually
like learns to grow a pair and like
stand up to him which which was nice to
see because like i said her dad celie's
dad in this is like literally the worst
he's like this is his biggest piece of
[ __ ]
which uh you know i'll get in a little
bit later
so very near the beginning when her when
celia's grandmother dies and she gets
very very upset about it she seems like
she doesn't
have a lot of friends um but not i mean
she's not like an unpopular she's not a
weirdo or anything like that but she is
kind of like very imaginative she also
has this thing she's kind of gotten
obsessed with this story that their
teacher told them in school this
actually happens over the christmas
break of 1957 which like i said it's the
southern hemisphere so their christmas
is like in the middle of summer um so at
the very beginning you kind of see them
in class and they're just like oh merry
christmas have a good two weeks off or
whatever the hell it is
i don't know how long it is in australia
you get two weeks in the us or at least
you used to when i was in school but i
don't know uh if it's longer that's who
knows uh somebody in australia you can
probably tell me
but yeah so it happens over christmas
break
so
uh the teacher before they leave had
read them this story and it's like a
folklore type story it's kind of it's
kind of [ __ ] up it's about these
monsters i guess they're kind of like
they they have like little drawings and
they kind of look like little trolls or
like ogres not trolls because they're
like regular human size but they sort of
look like ogre type things and they're
called hobias
and i don't know if this is a real uh
folklore type of thing in australia or
not it seemed like it was because they
had like this whole mythology about it
so the teacher is telling this messed up
story about this whole woods full of
hobias and in the story there's this uh
cranky old
old fart
and his uh and his wife and they live in
this house and they have this dog and
the dog is barking and
the dog is barking to warn them that the
hobias are like coming to get them
but the old man is just kind of like man
that dog just keeps [ __ ] barking so
the so the old man and this is a story
they're reading to like nine-year-old
children at the beginning and i was just
like wow the 80s were awaited for time
but uh yeah so the old man like cuts off
the dog's tail to get him to stop
barking i'm like i don't think that's
gonna work out the way you think but
okay
uh so then but then the uh you know the
dog is still barks obviously because
like hey the hobies are coming like out
of the woods and they're gonna like you
know take your wife or whatever and then
the old guy is kind of like okay well
that dog won't stop barking now so now
i'm gonna like cut off the dog's head
i'm just like
okay well i guess for sure he's gonna
stop barking now
uh but then ironically because he
essentially killed the dog the hobias
come and take his wife away
at which point the old guy
at the end of the story it's a fairy
tale uh you know puts the dog back
together and then the dog is fine
because at first i'm like reading this
story go this is [ __ ] up i don't like
this whole cutting up the dog because
he's barking and i was like all he's
trying to do is like protect you from
the monsters the [ __ ] you old old dude
but yeah so he puts the dog back
together at the end he's like oh i'm
sorry blah blah i don't know if the old
woman comes back or whatever because i
don't think they ever tell you the end
of the story now that i'm thinking about
it
but uh but yeah so
celia is kind of obsessed with this
story and she borrows the book over the
uh christmas holiday and so she actually
sees she not only sees like
hallucinations of her grandma sometimes
and like talks to her but she also sees
hobias so sometimes she'll look out her
window at night and see like this
monster hand like coming into her and
anybody that's like um a bad person or
she perceives as a bad person in her
life she sends tends to like see them as
hobias so that's what she calls
bad people um she sees them as like
monsters that are gonna come and get her
so there are some dream sequences in
there of where you actually see like
hobias like walking around the woods or
you see like celia seeing somebody
looking like a hobia and like i said
that's that's kind of where the horror
of the fantastical element comes in
so
celia's birthday is coming up and all
she wants is a pet bunny rabbit
now her dad who is a [ __ ]
will not get her one because as i said
there was this whole rabbit purge going
on in australia at the time because they
were considered a pest or an invasive
species and so the dad is basically no
they're vermin you can't have one and so
they get her a bike instead and she's
kind of like annoyed about it
um because she still really really wants
a bunny rabbit
so then um she has these there's these
kind of two rival gangs of kids
there's this other little girl her
name's stephanie and she seems like a
year or two older no i guess she's the
same age because she's in the same class
and she's just taller
and she's like the daughter of the cop
in town and she is also the worst i mean
she is just like a terrible person and
she got a bunny rabbit so she likes to
like rub it in the face of celia that
she didn't get one like for her birthday
so stephanie is kind of the head of this
other rival gang and they kind of all
play in this big quarry and like you
know they play sniper and they throw
rocks at each other and [ __ ] like that
so near the beginning of the story celia
um after she gets disappointed by not
getting a bunny for her birthday and
after her grandmother being dying so
she's kind of like not in a good place
but they have these new neighbors moving
next door the tanners so it's like a mom
and a dad and three kids
so uh happily
celia starts playing with the tanners so
they kind of form their own little gang
and they can like fight against the
other terrible gangs so there's that
whole thing going on
however
as time goes on
it uh comes to be discovered that the
tanners uh who are actually really nice
people and like i said celia
um really starts to bond with uh with
the mom i think her name is alice
with the mom of the tanner family not
only with the kids but uh the husband
alice's husband is kind of somewhere off
because i think like alice's husband and
celia's dad work at the same place you
know yeah they work at the same place so
he doesn't factor into it too much he
seems okay but um celia and
alice the mom of the neighbors they
really kind of start bonding because as
i said celia doesn't seem all that
connected to her own parents
uh because you know like i said her
dad's a dick and her mom's a little bit
kind of not really knowing what's going
on
so as the story goes on as i said
there's a there's a massive undercurrent
of you know the red scare that was going
on oh everybody's commies and
everybody's like turning people in and
all this other kind of stuff which kind
of which went on here as well uh in the
us but also went on in australia
you know they're even like they show
them at church they're all at church one
time and the priest is up there saying
oh this united peace uh group or
whatever it's a communist front and all
this other kind of stuff so there's all
that going on
and they find out that the tanners the
parents are actually members of the
communist party or are at least flirting
with it anyway and it's also hinted that
celia's grandmother uh was also
had beliefs along that line as well
because she had like a lot of books
about it in her room which celia's dad
ends up burning later on much to celia's
chagrin because that was her
grandmother's and she was uh you know
very very close to her grandmother and
she kind of starts to consider her dad
like a monster
so
after celia's dad
discovers that the tanners are maybe
have communist sympathies oh and not
only that but the dad is also trying to
like
have an affair
with alice with the neighbor's wife and
she's like not having it and he's just
like he'll be in the kitchen he's like
pushing up on her and stuff and she's
like get the [ __ ] off you know so like i
said he's the [ __ ] worst and he still
does that like even after he finds out
that she's you know maybe a communist
sympathizer or whatever
so the dad
goes behind he gets um alice's husband
fired from the plant by saying hey
they're you know the family they're
commies so he gets them fired and i
think celia at one point kind of
suspects that
um i don't know if she's like old enough
in the 50s or nine-year-old in the 50s
would have understood like that her dad
was trying to like hump
the neighbors
uh you know the neighbor lady but uh
basically the dad is just kind of like
okay well i'll buy you a bunny rabbit
like she always like celia always wanted
if you don't play with the tanner
children anymore if you don't ever if
you don't go over there anymore now at
first cieli is just kind of like no i'm
not doing that because i really like the
tanners um you know they're my friends
and i can't just like [ __ ] them over
like that
but after a while what she ends up doing
is she kind of which is probably the
same thing i would have done to be
honest with you because i was like hey
this is pretty smart kid she actually
was like oh yeah i totally won't and
then because she really wanted the bunny
rabbit and uh you know but then she just
goes and sees the tanners on the sly um
but of course she's nine so it doesn't
really
work out because she's not as sneaky as
she thought
so she gets this bunny rabbit
and she names it murgatroyd which i
think is like really really funny and
she just loves this [ __ ] rabbit she
just takes this rabbit everywhere
and
just
the relationship that she develops with
this rabbit i was just kind of like man
something bad is going to happen that
rabbit and i'm just like so upset about
it because i just knew it was going to
happen and i was just like i don't know
if i want to watch this anymore because
i'm going to get really upset
and uh so there was that but yeah so she
gets really close to the rabbit and then
uh as time goes on so like not only do
the tanners uh you know the guy loses
the job because celia is dead like narc
donum
but so they end up having to
move because he basically like stained
the dude's name all over town so now he
can't get a job anywhere he's an
electrical engineer i think and uh so
they're like well we have to move uh to
sydney and maybe he can find some work
there and uh so there's that whole
situation
and then so they end up having to move
away and then there's another thing too
where the australian government which i
guess they did this in real life but
they basically made it illegal to have
pet rabbits because as i said they were
trying to get rid of the rabbit menace
because they were considered pests or
whatever
so
you had to turn in if you had pat rabbit
you had to turn them in they didn't kill
him they just like put him in a zoo
and so celia of course is completely
devastated by this now the um her dad i
think that her dad's brother
was the cop that was steph because i
guess stephanie the girl that beat her
up was her cousin i think i think they
did actually bring that up because i
think that there was some relationship
between the dad and the cop cop also
kind of the worst uh not as bad as the
dad but he was kind of like a [ __ ]
and he actually started um
once he found out that the tanners were
communist sympathizers he would like
[ __ ] with their kids all the time and
you know just you know take other
people's words over theirs and [ __ ] like
that like even when that wasn't what
happened so they kind of like try to
started to like persecute them a little
bit
and he's also bound and determined that
celia is not going to have this rabbit
so she so when celia is at school one
day he actually comes there and like
basically takes her rabbit
and takes it off to the zoo at which
point celia is like flipping out and
she's like throwing stuff at him and
like i said rightfully so because he's
really a jerk about it and uh you know
what i mean i didn't feel bad uh because
some of the [ __ ] that happens to like uh
nothing bad happens to her dad
unfortunately but um you know the [ __ ]
that happens to the cop i was just kind
of like good you know what i mean so you
know um i don't want to spoil it because
i know a lot of people haven't seen this
but um
but what when what happened to the cop
happened to the cop i was just like good
does that make me a terrible person i
guess i just didn't feel bad at all so i
was like well stop sucking so much maybe
that would happen but uh but yeah
so he comes and takes the rabbit away
and uh so then celia is devastated uh
celia's mom finally as i said kind of
grows up she because she kind of finds
out about um celia's dad like trying to
pork the neighbor lady and also celia's
dad being behind you know alice's
husband getting fired uh so she's just
like oh my god this guy i'm married he
kind of blows so she actually kind of
like you know comes into her own and
decides that she's going to like stand
up for her daughter so she helps her
daughter um she's like we have to like
petition the government like to you know
get your rabbit back because she knows
how much this little girl loves this
[ __ ] rabbit and that was very very
clear in the movie because i was just
kind of like i mean she just took that
rabbit everywhere it was a big rabbit
you know it was like this big and it was
white with like one black ear super cute
uh but yeah so she wags this like the
rabbit's like half as big as she is and
she just like wags it around everywhere
so uh so yeah so they petition the
government and then like after however
long it is they're like okay fine like
you can get a permit
and uh you can have a pet rabbit if you
have a permit so celia is like super
excited and she's like okay you can go
back to the zoo and get it but
uh it doesn't work out the way you want
it at which point i was just kind of
like god damn it i just don't want to
watch this movie anymore it's like
really really upsetting me because like
i said anything happens to animals i'm
just i'm i'm really not about it so at
this point this like after this [ __ ]
happens this is kind of where
as i said there had been some horror
elements up to this where she keeps
seeing
like her grandmother not scary but well
one time it's kind of scary where she
kind of comes to the window but she
keeps seeing like hobias so she keeps
seeing like these like monster hands
come in
but at this point after the rabbit
incident and after the neighbors
move away because like i said that was
like her best friends and after that
whole situation so she's really like
emotionally
upset by all of this as you would be
and so she decides you know after the
cop takes her rabbit she her and like
all the other kids like her friends they
sneak out to the quarry and they
essentially do like some like [ __ ]
voodoo you know what i mean like some
black magic they kind of have this
bonfire and they make voodoo dolls of
the cop and of her dad and they're doing
this like really weird like which ritual
which like i said i guess that's kind of
why shutter considered this
a folk horror movie because it does have
like i said not only the folklore
element of the hobias
being kind of like a through line but
also there's this scene where she's
trying to essentially use like folk
magic or black magic to get back at at
the people in her life the men in her
life that uh that [ __ ] her over at
least from her perception so as i said
she sees
these evil people these guys that did
stuff to her like that that she sees
them as hobias so she thinks that it's
okay to like [ __ ] kill him and
honestly she made a voodoo doll of her
dad and and he found it and he like beat
the [ __ ] out of her like spanked her and
stuff and i was just kind of like i
don't know i kind of felt like i mean
the dad was such an unlikable character
i mean he was such an [ __ ] and i kind
of feel like in the movie they were
trying to like sort of soften him up
toward the end
and
i was like at that point i'm like i'm
sorry i'm not having it oh it's like you
know what i mean it's like i'm not
really sure if if uh
if the writer director was trying to
soften him up toward the end maybe maybe
trying to make him seem like not such a
terrible person but he was such a
terrible person at the beginning like he
had like zero pretty much zero redeeming
qualities and i'm like don't try to make
me like him now because i'm kind of
hoping he like gets hit by a bus um
unfortunately he doesn't but
i don't know it's
it's really hard to pull off when you
make a character that unlikeable at the
beginning it's really hard to like try
to redeem them toward them they're go
they're not all bad i'm like yeah that's
too late for that sorry that ship has
sailed so uh so yeah so the fact that
celia was making a voodoo doll and you
know sticking it and like you wanted to
kill her dad i was kind of like i can't
say i blame the kid i really don't uh
you know what i mean so i said that was
that whole thing too but that's kind of
i think where the folk horror aspect of
this comes
in where she was kind of trying to
essentially as i said use voodoo um to
get rid of the people in her life that
had [ __ ] her over
so as i said i don't really want to
spoil the ending of this um
it went in a direction i was like wow
they went there okay um so
again uh i can't say i felt too bad
about it
some people did say some reviews that i
said they thought that maybe the ending
was a little bit abrupt
but
i don't know i didn't find it all that
abrupt this kind of as i said this
reminded me a lot of
it's just a very
it's kind of like a dark
and it's not dark as in like the
physical sense because it's set in
australia in you know their summer time
so it's pretty much all sunny but it's
just dark in tone you know what i mean
it has like some funny stuff in it but
not really like it's a pretty
dark story and it does go some places um
especially in a coming-of-age type story
that are kind of grim and especially
considering the whole entire historical
context of what was going on in
australia at the time and not just
australia but you know with the red
scare and everything that was kind of
going on in the us and the uk as well
but it was interesting to see
the whole red scare thing like you know
kind of filtered through australian
culture because that's really something
you don't see a lot i mean i've seen a
lot of like red scare era type movies or
you know movies that are made about that
time period from a from an american
point of view or even from a british
point of view
i don't think i'd ever seen one from an
australian point of view before so uh
that was kind of interesting to see and
the whole thing about the rabbit purging
and stuff like that i mean
that was to me that was like the hardest
part of the movie to watch because a lot
of that news real footage and stuff
obviously it was real and it's like i
get it uh you know the rabbits they
reproduce very quickly and they eat
everything and you know if you're trying
to like grow food and [ __ ] like that yes
they are pests yes they are an invasive
species but
they're so [ __ ] cute and it's just
kind of like i don't
i don't know if i'd be able to just so
it was really really difficult for me to
watch and then when they did the whole
thing about oh we're now we're
confiscating everyone's pet rabbits
because you know we didn't want them
escaping and reproducing because we're
trying to get rid of this problem and
just the stuff that ends up happening
with celia with her rabbit that she
really has developed a very close
friendship to that was just really the
most upsetting part of the movie to me
so as i said if you're very soft-hearted
about animals which i am as well no
shame um then this might be a difficult
movie for you to watch it was very
difficult for me to watch but overall i
actually quite enjoyed this movie i find
it i don't know i found it just like
very intriguing as i said don't go into
it expecting it to be
scary or a horror movie and i think it
was a misnomer now it's mostly just
called celia but i have seen it called
celia child of terror and
that's again that's a misnomer it's
almost kind of like
it's setting it up to be like a killer
kid movie or
you know like evil child type sub genre
and it's not like that at all she's just
like a regular imaginative little girl
and there's all of these kind of larger
cultural forces going on and it's sort
of like you're seeing that time period
like filtered through
her perception and
you know you seeing it filtered through
that perception does end up like uh with
some tragic consequences or tragic
compares i didn't think it was all that
tragic but you know what i mean i'm a
terrible person so um you know if you've
seen it you'll know what i'm talking
about because i was just kind of like oh
well
should it shouldn't have been that way
so that's just what happened but yeah
uh so this is on shutter at the moment
uh and as i said if as long as you don't
go into it as long as you go into it
thinking that it's going to be like a
coming-of-age drama
with some horror elements in it then i
think you might enjoy it quite a lot one
of the main criticisms i saw of it was
some people didn't really like the
pacing or they thought that there were a
lot of things that were unresolved i
didn't really find that um i didn't find
it boring i didn't find it
uh you know particularly i don't know i
just i just thought it was like a pretty
compelling story and you know again a
perspective that i didn't
didn't really know much about or a time
period in history at least in uh in
australia that i didn't know a lot about
so i don't know i just thought it was
like a really good coming-of-age drama
um you know from a perspective that i
don't usually see in films as i said
it's on shutter at the moment as at
least as of this recording it's in their
folk horror collection so uh if you've
seen it let me know what you thought
about it uh if you haven't seen it then
i tried not to spoil the ending so uh
you know if you want to see it you can
and then we can have a discussion about
it in the comments and that will do it
for this flickers of fear our last of
our folk horror february reviews and uh
we'll be back for the next one i think
for march i might do monsters but uh
we'll see i'll think about it
but yeah so that'll do it for this one
and i will see you guys on the next one
bye